[Music]
[Music]
good morning millenials good morning
Millennials and those who don't identify
as Millennials good morning from your
goth emo host wake me up inside I can't
wake up save me from the dark I really
feel like the lead singer of Evanescence
today like with my long dark hair my
tatted up sleeves well at least you're
the lead of course oh my god I would
never compare myself to anything other
than the star and good morning from the
business woman specialist a truly
Hauser's blouse you're really focus with
a special except the tits are out today
oh I mean you know you just kind of keep
them what only not like titty girl oh
but this is but it's not looking good on
camera three days in a row of terrible
outfit I stopped watching the stream
here one because I find the comments
distracting like I like to see what
people like I like immediate feedback so
if I said something like about the Kevin
Hart thing which is like kind of
controversial like I want to see if
people are immediately upset at me but I
don't do it anymore because and then I
see my face and like I spent so long
getting ready today like I have a very
important meeting with do you know him
brian kelly of the points guy i know him
because you talk about him every episode
once an hour i know and you know i was
talking about him over the weekend to
someone and I'm like damn I have to stop
talking about him right but you already
knew that
yeah but you don't stopping you don't
want to happen that's fine you know I'm
a toy but I spent so long getting ready
today and it's like I know I'm gonna
look at the stream and it's like it's
like I might as well have just rolled
out of bed cuz they look the same I look
like I just got off the Mayflower yeah
with those puffy shoulders the myth Rock
but they I'm gonna see how I love just
like you know it's always good to know
what you look like you know you look
great do i yeah especially next to me
you know I do and now I have to sit up
straight the whole episode otherwise I'd
look like I have no torso you know when
that happens to a short girl well like
we're just and then legs I do I do look
okay today I'm not gonna lie and you
know that feels pretty good pretty good
you know by the way things you see oh we
do have another shirt over there are you
gonna change your shirt we also have
some merch I think that would be so
funny put on your coat because I don't
really know by the way I didn't even
look at you so funny like Ben will take
a picture and he'll be like how do I
look and I'm like I literally have no
idea doing with you and I literally like
I'm you're talking about it I don't even
see how you look you look good
he's definitely giving off pilgrim vibes
but that you knew that going in with
that shirt didn't I that I really did it
that sure was interesting cuz you know
it's like sexy bustier but also just
Seinfeld puppy shirt right and I
to do a little bit of both and it's just
not working and now sitting up straight
which I have to do I look so
uncomfortable on the stream and I don't
know you know what makes it we have the
iPad maybe like a little let go and let
God
what about like that how is that if we
did like a podcast everyday not a live
show I mean I don't like show time show
it's funny toast live my hair would be
in such better shape but I wouldn't have
to iron it every day and like I would
just be a better person but I love doing
this dream I love doing the stream my
hair would be in better shape my skin
would be better from not wearing makeup
also my emotional like happiness because
I could wake up like a true hour later
yes but also I do find that getting
ready and putting on makeup it's
equivalent of having cup of coffee
agreed like if I just white my eyes
right now like go like that I wouldn't
have the same amount of energy that I do
now except I did we watch an old episode
of the morning breath where and I know
we spoke about this last week I actually
do remember that where we recap our
Chelsea Kennel Club protests and my
Harry Styles interaction and I was
wearing no makeup it was a day I was so
hungover and it actually was very funny
hungover but I think like that gets old
quickly like you couldn't do that every
day yeah and it's the people do love it
though
truly so sometimes you have to do it
well don't worry so but I'm sure we can
I haven't seen you you know it was the
least relaxing weekend I've had an oil
meet you can I tell you the craziest
thing that happened to me so I was in
Dallas quickly for the weekend and I
came back yesterday and I'm on the
flight I was watching The King's Speech
just because it was the only thing on my
death welcome weird it was a long thing
on my Netflix downloads that hadn't been
expired yet did your plane have TVs it
did um I just didn't want to get out my
headphones with the cord totally is
really what it was about and also I just
I have to I need then any talk about
American Airlines but I'm watching The
King's Speech I have my ear pods in and
I hear an announcement and I said take
them out and I hear please come to the
front it's a Code Red
over the speaker what and everyone is
like up and up right I'm like what the
[ __ ] is a Code Red because like that's
Bell Reddy's the worst of the know like
code yellow is like not bad code red is
bad code Rani's there's nothing it's
like there's nothing because yeah words
like DEFCON 1 right there's no def def
or calm there's
depakote though everyone is like sitting
upright left or right you're freaking
out there's a couple like a flight
attendant and a person like mulling in
the aisle it doesn't it's not like it's
not like terror vibes like I don't see
like a knife or anything so you would
hear a struggle - yeah and no one was
like going towards the cockpit I so the
content it was safe the cockpit was safe
so we're all just like looking around
like what the [ __ ] I'm freaking out
obviously Code Red so she gets back on
like they're talking about you maybe I
wish no I was minding my own business
and I had my hood up they didn't even
know I was oh right okay and then she
gets back on and she was like if anyone
is a licensed medical professional like
please come to the front and I was like
[ __ ] if only doctor the officer and so I
guess someone like wasn't feeling well
maybe it was like I don't know what they
never even told us when we did
that's a Code Red but a coke you can't
say code right on there didn't ever get
up um for the doctor yeah right no I
just think like if I like went through
all the treachery of like med school
like the loans the long hours the tests
the residency and like that there's an
opportunity where it's like does anyone
here a doctor like that would be like
the best part of being a doctor I
getting to be the center of attention
and a hero
right I'm like all your loans is for
that you know right but I also saving
people's lives definitely like we're in
any like you know MD use on the plane
but there might have been like a few
chiropractors who stood up right or like
someone who had like benadryl on yeah I
may be like a psychiatrist or something
you know people and places are weird
about that like I've been at a hotel
many times where I'm like - the fart
doesn't kill you guys got in the Advil
and they like won't give it you like you
can't get out just like schools
yeah cuz like what if the advil kills
you or something I don't know but that's
so so I'm a try if you ever see me in an
airport and you need any sort of drugs
just know that I have on me at all times
like advil excedrin Advil PM gas-x pepto
and I think that's it that's good to
know
always because I've been sick many time
up on the plane ya know for sure oh and
they just any never told us what was
happening and that's just so rude when
you say Code Red on an airplane
speaking of Code Red on an airplane we
spoke about last week Bethenny's
traumatic experience with her allergy
Fiasco and you were talking about it
this morning it's a bunch of people at
DM to me to watch Danny Pellegrino's
Instagram story first all day they feel
like we know is just like a great
content creator great content creator he
does amazing work he does make it work
like great bravo memes all that stuff
and he'll be respected in the field as
well of course totally as a Bravo holic
kind of sore mm-hmm and he did a whole
deep dive on Bethenny's history with
fish and it's like not a politically
correct thing like he's brave because I
would never do that like you can't
second guess someone's allergies it's
like a very personal thing we're like
they're very self-conscious about it but
he did make some valid points about her
history with fish and he didn't and he
along the way gave her the benefit of
the doubt okay so maybe she can have
this type of fish this type if it's not
that type of fish you guys should watch
before it expires I don't even know if
it has yet it's worth the deep dive it's
worth the deep dive and it just it makes
you think
and speaking of diving off the deep end
we are gonna dedicate today's entire
show to the Golden Gloves because it was
really light as we watch it right and it
was a night where everything happened
but also nothing really happened you
know right I have a lot of thoughts
right so let's go into our general
thoughts and then we'll go into a few
specific stories that I've sort of the
most viral moment were saying actually I
mean the best part of any award show was
red carpet which I fell asleep and woke
up and I was like actually upset like I
had waited around for that stupid
countdown to the red carpet I was on and
I'm like this is so great they like
predict what people are gonna wear I
mean they're like here's the 37 people
were excited to see it's like the
longest list cuz they have to fill two
hours and it was from four to six I know
four to seven yeah cuz number six four
two six four to six and six to eight so
at five o'clock I'm like oh the
countdown is over like no way they're
doing a two hour countdown but they were
so I like watch a little bit night rips
off and I woke up at seven and I was
like some rightist an hour of the red
carpet when I had sat through an hour of
that trash I actually I'm done with red
carpets no II still to eat maintains the
integrity of a good red carpet yes but
like red carpets as a whole are gone
gone it's just like everyone's just
trying to get that sound what bite and
it's so they're sound bite was gotten
today I would this morning I was getting
ready and I said to uh I the first it
was the first thing I said in the
morning so obviously you know my voice
my dictation was often did Alexa play
God I said Alexa play Gavin DeGraw see
trolls me she G goes I'm sorry I don't
know who Glavine de Gras is all that
[ __ ] I was I felt like I was on the
morning toast it's totally you can't
escape it really so when you were like
the first thing I said this morning to
and I'm like who else could it be
besides I know it was Alexa
and she totally trolled me because I
thought she would understand like it was
and when I said it I was like oh that's
funny if like Claudia were here she'd be
like who's glad right yeah and there I
was and then she said I don't know let's
see if it works on people's Alexa play
Glavine to Gras hopefully it works for
everyone will check and I were just
talking about cuz the red carpet really
is the best part and how like I don't
think I could ever be famous because
nobody on the red carpet at these award
shows wears a bra right with their
little tits that just like stand up on
their own and like before their big tits
that stand up on their own great no it's
just like
I learnt even see one girl wearing a bra
I didn't even like a strapless bra no I
didn't I didn't try and find one but no
there were it was a braless affair no
all I think is that cuz they take those
pictures from this side with like a
little tit popping out but that's just
where they lose me in terms of their
related bills thanks wash a Ronan oh my
god boobs
her boobs but like they her dress was
amazing they stayed right there no I
always think about that and it's like I
would be so up to a because I would just
be like tugging on my bra the whole
night he's right you'd like come like
with the third love tags sticking out
and they don't have tags tagless
speaking up there love love love and by
the way we've been talking about their
love for a while and now Toaster it's
like our getting their packages like
time the time has come and their raves
the reviews are in rate their rate I'm
so glad I mean for me it's like bras are
so specific so I like a certain type of
I like it's maybe it's not for everyone
but so far because the you take a quiz
online together the type of bra and
everyone loves it I feel like I'm a bra
connoisseur because if a bra is good for
me it's good for anyone yeah nobody came
into a bra store they're like well what
do you handle my issues right you can
take on the world
no but like the questions they ask you
on the quasar like deeply personal and
like if someone in the store was like to
experience like overflow I'm like no
yeah what's that for boob
I'm Saoirse Ronan I don't have overflow
you know so if you want to get your
third love bra here's how to do it
third love knows there's a perfect bra
for everyone so right now they're
offering our listeners to 15% off your
first order go to third love comm slash
morning toast now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today and just listen
to your fellow toasters it's true some
of those [ __ ] in Hollywood need to
get on the curb like we're seasoned
experts in this field and I feel
the comfortable giving bra
recommendations you know look I would
never give a diet recommendation and if
I did don't listen to me you look so
good oh thank you but like it not off of
a real diet right we're like an exercise
recommendation but like bra snacks you
can trust me totally on snacks okay so
let's go through just your overall
thoughts on the globe's before we get
into specific moments because I didn't
watch any red carpets because I just got
home at at 8 o'clock and I actually
happened to watch the whole thing
um actually had to go back to watch the
intro cause you said that Andy Samberg
and Sandra oh we're good so startingly
funny so I went back and watched it and
I agreed with you but you know what's so
funny is like the toasters and I and I
was like we usually agree and I put a
picture on our Instagram and I just want
to know what everyone thought cuz like
to be honest maybe I liked it so much
because I had little to no expectations
for them I didn't know if they had
chemistry had no Sandra it was funny
she's like a serious doctor on Grey's
Anatomy you know right um and maybe I
was just so pleasantly surprised that I
thought it was better than it was but I
really enjoyed it I can't focus we're
funny like I enjoyed it however like my
expectations were so low and it's like
if James Corden were up there making
those jokes I really like really that's
it and it's like every time they made a
joke I felt like Samantha from sex and
city like sweetie you made a little joke
right no I was like good for you no Andy
samberg's really funny and someone wrote
in they toast and I could totally agreed
he has like a very specific sense of
humor and it you could tell that he
wrote a lot of the jokes like it was
very like dry like sarcastic
it's like satirical I hate that word cuz
you can't say it without sounding like
satirical satire CO and I was just
really surprised by Sandra oh but you
could tell she was nervous but she just
went for it and she had a serious moment
where um I didn't know if she was joking
or not and everyone in the audience was
laughing when she said like about being
the change but then someone else told me
that it was also like a something for a
bird box so I didn't know if it but I
think she was being serious but everyone
was laughing but it was just like she
didn't do a good transition from just
jokes to funny right except when she did
that Asian mom face like I don't have an
Asian mom but it was so fun that was so
fun I didn't understand the pepsin joke
but I don't think it was meant for me um
oh it wasn't meant for you as as we now
know right um I don't know
they were just handing out like Harper
and Medicaid I mean I'm Jewish I get
heartburn and I'm fat but I don't
I thought me because I sometimes when I
drink like you get flushed I mean that
was what did they call it it was it
wasn't bidding as a brand name like they
knew I said
they said it was like like the Asian I
forgot know whatever and then then they
said for the old people to at the
Kaminski at the Kaminski table Minsky
table and they already got your mom her
mom was actually doing the Asian mom
face that was so funny so funny uh [ __ ]
was it oh and what Amberg because Sandra
Oh like was great but a nice and mark
was really like a great comedic anchor
anchor and he like sometimes when you
have to say those jokes that are just
like but uh
and they're cringy he really delivered
them like in a way that they moved
forward like there were no crickets or
awkward pauses yeah so I felt like
together they were a very good duo also
they didn't take over the whole show
like sometimes these hope these shows
forget like it's not about the host it's
not the hosts Bar Mitzvah like the host
is there to move the show along quickly
and speedily so they don't over the 11
o'clock time limit and the Golden Globes
only went over like 10 or 15 minutes
because they rushed through everything
when they were reading the nominees they
didn't even have time to pan to the
people they were like Lady gaga
a star was born boom like they went so
fast like they didn't have time to
capture her face and I appreciate it too
much it's called Asian flush and it's
because when I guess it wouldn't agen
people drink their feet though you get
red so do i i get like me back to bed
but I get hot face you know I get slushy
we should be taking pepsin I didn't know
that good to know thank you go to Sandra
oh yes it moved along very very nicely
brevity and speed are key when it comes
to things like they were very savage
about cutting people speeches off except
for a few people who were just trying to
say something important yeah and they
turn the music off right except for the
guy from Green Book who started to just
give a summary of his film right um and
it's like notice if we wanted to see it
we would have right and we've been
seeing the trailer for an all night it's
like I was there so I know what your
film is about so like when he was like
turn it off and just just proceeds to
read the Wikipedia back of the book
right you know clip notes right so also
did the show make you want to see any
movies in particular [ __ ] what's so
funny it's like the Golden Globes are
the first one and usually as someone
like I love like I'm invested in movies
but I'm not like an art feel like I
don't love film so usually I see like
the one or two of the most popular ones
and then when awards season starts like
whatever starts winning I'm like oh I
should see that and I do
I hadn't seen one movie besides the
stars born in I don't really count back
because I was a very mainstream like and
usually by now I will have seen one or
two and then like I'll see a couple
I didn't see any and none of them even
looked remotely interesting except for
if Beale Street could talk because
Regina King stole the show
yeah her arms and she's dress she's such
a good actress
she'll never not be grace from Legally
Blonde for me but because she was so
transformative in that role you know hey
great her arms like I started she was
the first person I saw on date when I
woke up and she was on TV I'm like I'm
her chilton mazing her arms her son was
being like a little bit of like I
attention hog on the mic with Ryan
Seacrest but it was his first show he
was excited right and I'm sure like she
was like I've done this a million times
like please yeah and take the pressure
off it kind of made me want us to see
green book I'm not going on which one
was on her shali
going around and playing piano oh yeah a
one in some major categories and I guess
I could see Bohemian Rhapsody
oh me too oh me too I heard it was good
and you know what's so funny is like I
read one and he said the thing about the
teeth how do you exhume the body know
one thing that that I read a critique of
Bohemian Rhapsody from like a fancy
Hollywood like hypocrite
and they're like what we loved the movie
we didn't think and included enough of
you know Freddie Mercury's background in
his childhood I'm like oh damn now it
seems like I would like it
miss height that said that Bohemian
Rhapsody is Dini as hell okay which is
like fine if that movie theater that we
like the no way okay Sophia yeah no but
I really felt out of touch and also the
Vice table looked lit and they seemed
really passionate about their film you
know but I was having this conversation
with Ben last night because I'm in see
vice but what's like a satire no cuz
they were saying he was the greatest
vice president like in the history and I
was like from my understanding like to
people like Dick Cheney no they were
great they were saying the most powerful
that he had so much power as vice
president and I don't we have to watch
the movie to see the untold true story
of what he did with it
okay cuz like when it comes to politics
like I don't think like Hollywood was in
love with Bush and Dick Cheney right no
I dad is very much in line with this
what was it when I was watching it i Ben
was like it's a satire I'm like I don't
think that's I don't know uh no I think
it's it's very negative towards dick and
I owe and Christian mail said I want to
thank Satan for the inspiration I Google
that's like who does he play in this
film like who does like Dick Cheney he
played Dick Cheney that's why he thinks
hair-and-makeup team so much they
transformed him completely oh wow that
is impressive isn't that crazy
he's huge like and he's big like white
hair guy speaking of white hair Jim is
Curtis did she dye her hair did she go
gray I thought she was great no she was
like salt and pepper but she had white
hair oh oh I don't mean she also wore
all white like see people think maybe
she dyed her hair like to go with the
look I thought she looks great
yeah she's Freaky Friday I didn't watch
red carpet so I didn't have many
opinions but who do you think was best
dressed like I only saw people look I
didn't around the red carpet but when
she came out and it pains me because I
really don't like her Saoirse Ronan
looked so unbelievable like that dress
was the prettiest dress I've ever seen
in my life but I mean I mean Lady Gaga
was stunning Lady Gaga was my tempo Judy
Garland like with the blue they loved it
it was a little unrealistic because that
award show is special in that it's it's
table seating it's like wedding seating
and she was like in this little chair
and like people were trying to walk
through her dress and like interested
Lupita Nyong'o almost walked on her
dress when she was coming out Lady Gaga
had just won for shallow um it didn't
seem practical but it was gorgeous it
was gorgeous
oh stop it it's just it's such a such a
perfect tone for the rest of award
season I thought she looked incredible I
love that color of plenty vibes all the
way there cause it was teeny tiny dang
she messed your hair - her dress which
is just commitment on another level and
it's just like that's like the Gaga in
her like anybody dress was the Stephanie
the Ali
this was the Gaga yeah she looked so
beautiful with her small arm and you
know who is there very quietly like I
didn't see a picture of her on the red
carpet and it's - Bradley Cooper
Bradley Cooper until like like they pan
to her for one second was his wife Irina
Shayk um she was white red carpet -
mother of his child
I don't think legally married life
partner regardless right they seem like
they're really unhappy together that's
what I get from them ever since that
shot of them at Wimbledon like I'll
never forget that right and you've been
in public where like you're fighting
with mom fighting with banner like
you're fighting with Zack and like you
know you just can't get that mug off
your face and she couldn't believe you
that famous [ __ ] get the mug off your
face I thought she did a good job last
night of being like supportive and
looking happy and and not you know
playing into the rumors that he's in
love about I mean he is I think it's
mutual but you also Catherine zeta-jones
such incredible I mean I just love her
and you know I know this is really about
to say but I get her husband confused
with Michael Douglas that's her husband
Michael Fox
Michael J Fox who's that I don't know I
just know they're like two old guys and
one of them is sick and in the other one
we're both sick but the one that you're
thinking of is the other one and then
he's sick I think he had like throat
cancer and the other one has Parkinson's
yeah
so they're just like both older sick men
named Michael every bit of enthusiasm do
you ever see that episode which of
Michael J Fox in the Parkinson's and
obviously Larry David no okay
I just get them confused and it's like I
know like she's always there as like his
like plus one but like she is it you
know yeah and she is she is like doing
it for women you know of a certain age
of all I totally I totally agree um okay
so let's break down that was just the
general overview who else looked really
good Oh Nicole Kidman by the way I
didn't see anything up her cuz she was
um she okay so I wasn't down to the red
carpet you know and was so stupid but
they did do a good deep dive on a Cole
Kidman because she's been going to award
shows for literally 20 years and she's
always best dress or like top five and
she was very understated she wore our
burgundy that we Bordeaux Bolivia's
wedding long-sleeve sequined dress I was
thinking like I really wish I were that
to let me it's wedding she's just so
tall and they did they said something
really interesting about her like she's
a tall woman and tall women usually shy
away from wearing such high heels and
she has a short husband and she never
she ties away for wearing a five-inch
elo and I love her I love her okay let's
go through the list of winners maybe
it'll bring back some guys movies Best
Motion Picture Drama Bohemian Rhapsody
um you know I thought that was a fair I
wouldn't know I thought it was a fair
assessment I haven't seen none of the
movie and I already wanted to see it but
I hadn't gotten a chance to and now I
think it's on demand I need to see by
Panther oh my god you know I never saw
two and Ben was like rooting for it the
whole time cuz he saw and he said it was
the best movie I ever saw yeah I think
he saw it was a can they both said that
so we should have a screening yeah I
mean maybe I love we like those Marvel
movies transcend like Wonder Woman also
did that into like serious
oscar-nominated films have you heard
anything about Aquaman yes I heard it
was horrible
I heard that too I'm still gonna see I
heard it I think we heard from the same
person really oh okay so he's just
writing rumors that's fine I'm gonna see
it and I'm gonna love it I don't care
also Amber Heard was there and like I'm
sorry I love her I didn't like address I
didn't like her dress but I just it's
not even about her dress because it's
she's like the
beautiful woman in the world like in
like that's her title category he was
like the most googled woman like what
last year yeah and I just like need her
to get back together with you on musk I
know like or start dating Jason Momoa
even though he's very happy with Lisa
but so happy I know it's like his
happiness is annoying no I know it's
like you're in Hollywood like come on
yeah be unhappy like everyone else right
Best Motion Picture Musical or Comedy
Green Book which made me want to see it
look at a no one that's the piano one
okay maybe crazier occasions which like
was robbed so I was also how a star is
born not musical or comedy its musical
was it in drama what was the drama
that's so weird isn't that weird
well actually okay it's not considered a
musical just because it has music a
musical it's like if we're just talking
in then we start singing for no damn
reason and ever let act like it's not
room oh well they kind of do that he's a
jerk but she's in the part and I and
she's like I know she was writing a song
like it was in the context like when in
the movie star is going like I said I
was music on stage and this according to
yeah between a movie with me to get a
musical like dream girls dream girls was
in a musical because they were on stage
and in the recording studio I've been
directed when dream girls was nominated
it wasn't in the musical but like when F
he's like singing like jefe jefe you got
so jefe baby
and when she's singing uh that you know
the song dream girls actually oh yeah
but she was on stage but dream girls she
broke out it yeah dream girls might have
been in musical it's an interesting -
hey so when when she didn't win forward
with the day discrepancy ok Best
Performance by an actress in a motion
picture drama Glenn Close the wife so
everyone was all up in arms that Lady
Gaga was overlooked and she was snubbed
and I just have to say like the win the
wins for Lady Gaga SME we're just where
they should have been and I said it when
I saw the movie like the movie was great
the music was phenomenal that's why it
won Lady Gaga's acting very subpar and
underwhelming there's no way she should
have won and she was in a category with
like June for her it really is an honor
to be nominated but especially given the
the caliber of people who were nominated
with her there was no way she deserved
to win no offense but I'm glad she went
for shallow because it was the best song
right and it's what won for best song
and I like
cuz cuz of step survives who was she and
separate well she was the main woman who
orchestrated the whole thing
do you think her and nicole kidman said
hi to each other last night I'm sure
they they seem like they're on you know
good terms yes Stepford sisters yes I
get sick together best performance by an
actor in a motion picture drama rami
malek Bohemian Rhapsody I think I mean I
didn't see it but I think well deserved
he's very um he transformed he's very um
like mon monotonous and like subdued and
like kind of creepy i missed his speech
i think i was on the phone with you
maybe he was just very like sighting and
you want to know why someone finally
remember but I know him from Twilight
right so he was playing sir this like
mysterious vampire that's why he he just
can't get rid of that Stan he's from
like that robot show on USA right which
wasn't that popular I don't think so I
don't I don't know how you get to become
that from mr. robot it's cuz he was into
it and I think it's also because if you
really look like the person well but I
don't know Christian Bell was British I
really expected him because he was so
transformative in the fighter I expected
him to be Bostonian
he's so transformative American hustle
but he was the Grossman right no he
really like becomes every actor that he
plays it's like that's why he always
gets nominated I kiss his cousin he need
a hundred pounds to play Dick Cheney oh
did he it wasn't about to it I think was
both okay like anything goes double chin
right Central's breast performance by an
actress rests performance I win today
she did say I got breast on the mind the
third love cousin breast performance by
an actress of course who's interested by
a breast performance by an actor the
breast performance by an actress in a
motion picture Musical or Comedy Olivia
Colman
the favorite oh the Joe Alban movie is
that the Joe almond yeah and that's why
Taylor was there he wasn't nominated but
he was in the movie and that's when I
realize I'm like oh I know nothing about
the film industry because Emma Stone
being in a movie like that's Oscar
nominee like that's something I would
know about like last year Lowell and
there was a very similar movie that came
out with Margot Robbie
uh Mary Queen of Scots right and Saoirse
Ronan very confusing I get my time
pieces period things all confused that's
when I was like I really didn't know a
lot about what was going on last night
in terms of like the the TV and film
that were nominated but when that came
out I was like oh I really don't know
what's going
right and then it was funny because both
of those girls were nominated for Best
Supporting Actress and it's like the
movies called the favorite it's like if
one of them won it would be the favorite
you know how do you feel about ritualize
Rachel vice you mean I was gonna say
what do they introduce her like that no
cuz apparently that's how she's how her
name is pronounced but then why is it
spelled with a w well it's German like
my she's Jewish right yeah and so she's
awaiting Daniel Craig yes and so it was
like very legit when I was in college I
took a theater class and they were like
one of the assignments was to go see a
play that wasn't a musical and I'm like
are you kidding me and ever much like
the local theater but I took it as an
opportunity you know to hit Broadway and
see betrayal with Daniel Craig and
Rachel was like on-screen romance with
the off-screen lovers truly one of the
worst things I've ever done I got in
trouble it was such a serious theater I
got in trouble by the woman behind me
for eating popcorn too loud that's like
that was the hutzpah I experienced after
horn is allowed snack nutritionist don't
stir it up theater best director Alfonso
Cuaron Romo was that George Washington
know that um aroma was the international
film the Netflix movie it was an
international film too and when it what
been like doesn't so it was either one
that looks like Ben no no no that was
spider-man no Ben was watching with me
and they did like best foreign film and
like Roman 1 and Ben was like oh yeah I
heard that was good I was like you did
yes it's sorry Phil it's on Netflix like
it's not far it's right here no but it
can't be Barnabas without Mexico's only
foreign film if it's very difficult to
find
I know but Netflix is democratizing the
film industry Oh true Best Performance
by an actor in a motion picture Musical
or Comedy Christian male advice seems
like he deserves it just for the weight
gain alone that's dedication no actors
like who can gain and lose like 30 or 50
pounds like for a role like teach me
right and it's like anyone if you had to
lose weight for a role like okay sure
like I lose yeah imagine having to gain
100 pounds do it I would rather lose
weight thing anyway for a role of course
even though one assume because I'm sure
the studio like sends in all the big way
trainers chef all that stuff
Best Supporting Actress in a motion
picture Regina King if the L student
could talk didn't see it but I think she
deserved it just by her
yes I agree Best Supporting Actor in a
motion picture Mahalo Ali green book
seemed deserved he's like I showed the
Timmy the sham La Salle amazed I thank
you I really wanted to talk about that
just back to my Hershel alley like he's
just immediately it gets respect by
everyone in Hollywood look it's nice
he's just like stamps with this fact so
straight you know I want to talk about
Timothy shell MA for a minute because
I'm not on board okay I'm just I mean
this doesn't surprise me I just don't
understand the obsession you have a type
and it's an opposite like you have a
type of people that you don't like and
it's people who just leave a little bit
of an older Jacob said I'm older well no
respected Jacob sorry is a female I mean
sorry he is a male million Bobby Brown
yes like his immediately loved revered
and respected by everyone for being a
child who was in one thing like that's
not fair that's all I have to say and
like I just I don't get him at all no I
don't know what I might I think he's
free and what does he famous for I'm
called me by your name yes and is he 16
or 60 both yeah like I don't get is he a
child
he's a child and he has that arranged
relationship with little Moss Billy rose
death yeah whatever that doesn't seem
arranged they seemed like note and he
says it's very arranged so my god they
seemed perfect for each other whoever
arranged it no I just I don't understand
his career and I don't understand so
many things about him that's all I want
okay I don't think he's for you when I
was scrolling Instagram this morning and
he obviously put up a thing because like
they do what they're doing to Millie
Bobby Brown they're gonna ruin him
I said mental note disgust till Timothy
Chalmette Tillis to LaMichael oh man um
oh and his name Sam Rockwell's do you
know him of course the guy's husband and
was in the worst movie ever three words
outside ebbing Missouri but he ended up
being the hero in that movie Sorna oh
yes yeah yeah your [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
he was bad that was good but he played
short chubby bush you know I didn't know
that and I did see Leslie Bibb with her
brown hair sitting that I loved that
she's such a supportive wife know I love
her so it makes me love him and they're
empty rights kindness blinds about them
like they are real they're good people
and you know who else I love and I
wonder if they spoke Alicia [ __ ] long
legs and Becky Bloomwood because isla
Fisher was there with Sacha Baron Cohen
why doesn't he ho
to anything he he really died like if
only he got half the respect that
Timothy sha'lame gets if only no he's
truly a talent like a worldwide talent
and Heyman
I love dudes like such good philanthropy
like for the community and nobody cares
about them I love them if I were in
Hollywood I want to be friends with them
when I was in Hollywood I met them at a
party and like it was very difficult for
me just to sit next time and not be like
very nice my wife know it's like the
things that we love about them is like
one confessions of a shopaholic to like
him like Kazakhstan I'll add Dayton
[ __ ] where it's like everyone
loves them for like other [ __ ] and I
just like I want to talk to them about
that you know right right Bachelorette
men like you are the reason I left
Finland you know that's really not what
people know about them and that's
annoying you want to talk about the
recent fish crisis no I feel so terrible
for the whole fiscal family best
original score' no motion picture Justin
Hurwitz first man I guess we're getting
what the hell his first met never heard
of it Claire Foy who the [ __ ] is Claire
for never heard oh the Queen okay for
now oh no she's getting replaced very
sad stuff Best Original Song motions
pictures shallow a star is born okay I
didn't know Mark Ronson wrote it I mean
I'm not surprised because everything
Mark Ronson touches turns to gold and
he's the underrated hottest most
eligible bachelor in Hollywood who comes
from like a socialite rich family like
he has money but he also comes from
money like what's better than that um
loved him and I didn't know he was a
part of it and it made the most sense
but when they when they made the
announcement they were a cello and then
the man came on the speaker and he was
like the award is being accepted by Mark
Ronson that's all they said and there
were four [ __ ] people on stage and
didn't even say Lady Gaga and I was
thinking I'm like did she not write it
weird maybe like and Mark Ronson paid
back but then I saw on Twitter like they
all got it all four of them I think they
get badges so now we need to talk about
cuz those are the most important
categories Lady Gaga's path to e ganas
because if she wins if she doesn't win
Best Actress but she wins and what does
she have already she has an Emmy
let me just look it up because she's
nominated for like all four right so
it's Emmy Grammy Oscar Tony Golden
Globes don't even matter
oh so she has an Emmy I believe for
American Horror Story
she has Grammys of course she needs an
Oscar and I guess she needs a Tony look
this is this is
PopSugar 'not so true although it seems
like gaga has won a ton of awards ready
she's actually still a ways away from
the ego designation the vast majority of
Gaga's awards are from the music
industry including six Grammys she does
have two Golden Globes for American
Horror Story and now first stars one but
those don't count towards that you got
what about an Emmy she has an Oscar for
a song cuz it says even if Gaga wins oh
no sorry she doesn't like even if I got
wounded for wyden happens to you
right even if Gaga wins one or more
Oscars for a star was born she'd still
only be halfway there she needs an Emmy
and she needs a Tony yes she has a
Grammy
I believe that she'll get those things
but the Oscar I think for her will be
the hardest to get so she can get it
right now then she can work towards the
other thing yeah okay okay so that's the
Tony might be hard for her to get
because Tony's are a lot like uh like
theater she doesn't do that but she does
know she but you can't wait and guess
you well but like but like in the
foreseeable future she's really focusing
on her acting career and her biggest
residency like Tony doesn't come from
that no but but she could get one is she
just like once two plus she works she
has a Tony Bennett he who wasn't he god
jump I just got one Elton John would be
Goldberg I think mm-hmm okay now let's
get into some of the specific moments
like when Chrissy Nets called Alison
Brie a [ __ ] and then Chrissy Mets a
good head said she be virtually rebuffed
it she brutal erupted because there are
pictures of them together like they've
met and it seems like they're friends so
it seemed like it was a joke and there
is no like the clip that what was it
Entertainment Tonight or whoever had
there was a bleep on it but that means
someone heard it cuz there's like a
10-second delay on live streams so that
because of that reason alone so like
when they hear a curse word that they
get ten seconds to bleep it out so
someone had to have heard it in order to
put the bleep on right pre-show co-hosts
Simpson told page six that she believes
Mets might have called her a babe you
know what I'm choosing to believe that
she did say [ __ ] because she said do I
she's a [ __ ] like I said like that's my
[ __ ] she like she's a [ __ ] like but as
a I don't know it could've been a joke
for she's bitching it could have been a
joke for sure but no he the lead-up is
unfortunate but also the lead-up to it
before they cut from her and before she
didn't realize her mic was on like they
were like do you know how somebody she's
like do I like she didn't seem
overwhelmingly happy to
somebody was coming up next right she
said it's terribly unfortunate anyone
think would think much less run a story
that was completely fabricated
I adore Alison would never say a bad
word about her anyone I'm sure hope she
knows my heart and then Alison Brie
posted an Instagram story of a picture
of the two of them saying nothing but
love for Chrissy Mets rumors can't keep
us down okay but here's the thing about
Chrissy Mets is that I've heard both
from legitimate and non-legitimate
sources like she's a terror look she's
very difficult to work with she's a diva
extraordinaire like you can't look at
her on set like I've heard crazy things
about her yeah I haven't heard anything
like I heard her and many more don't get
along like many mores a precious gem of
a human who can't deal with the diva
like tendencies of one Chrissy Matz what
yeah that is so wild
but I mean Alison Brie being a [ __ ]
like but by the way she couldn't have
directed her de venise at someone more
deserving like I hate Elsa I don't hate
her I have no feelings towards her
because like she's never played like a
character that I was in love with but if
someone were to tell me that she's a
[ __ ] like I wouldn't be shocked ya know
or not even AB it's just like she thinks
her [ __ ] doesn't stink I'm like she
keeps getting work even though I think
like if you've got her like her Q score
like statistically what does the
audience think about Alison Brie I don't
think she's like a genuine look like a
relatable or like well-liked actress
like by the audience
nobody at court but by Hollywood like
she is she put her in everything I know
well I think it's weird that she's
married today Franco I don't you it's so
like the weirdest pairing ever it's the
weirdest pairing because I just binge
watched privilege which is the greatest
show either no date Franco's in it okay
Lucy Hale and they're the cutest [ __ ]
level of all time and that show only had
one season like it dispar for joanna
garcia swisher dresses for her and also
justice or the other sister who like
looks like khloe kardashian right except
she was so skinny like which is so weird
because she just seemed like dude there
are people like that who like from their
face like you don't think they're like
so skinny then you look at their body
like damn they're skinny butts cuz I get
fillers but it's just such a good show
and it's like I'm reaching all these old
shows and it's really showing me like
the protagonists of each show is the
worst person alive Marissa Cooper the
worst person Susan Mayer Susan Mayer
Carrie Bradshaw Serena van der Woodsen
and honestly Megan Smith from privilege
like was really [ __ ] annoying to also
I started I've been like in a deep dark
depression ever since I stopped I
finished Desperate Housewives like I
think no TV is worthy so
was like you know I'm just gonna watch
it again and I started the pilot and
like I just couldn't do it but you know
they called her in the first episode
Susan Mayer hmm I thought that was weird
that is weird we're like Mary Alice was
narrating it's like in my neighbor Susan
Mayer weird it just kind of doors maybe
you like she pronounced it wrong and
like no one corrected a because they
didn't it's gonna go anywhere
next story Emma Stone yells I'm sorry
after Sandra Oh's sick aloha burn at the
Golden Globes Emma Stone is still very
sorry for a loja during Sandra omen Andy
samberg's opening monologue at the 76
annual Golden Globes Oh sharp Lee burned
the hell out of the film in which Stone
started as a character of Hawaiian
Chinese heritage as well as Scarlett
Johansson starring role in the
live-action version of the iconic
Japanese movie goes to the show in the
monologue shouted out crazy rotations as
the first film with an Asian American
lead since ghost in the shell and Aloha
prompting with a prompting stone TL I'm
sorry
while we're bum we didn't get to see
stones reaction which makes me think
that it was unprompted it was or
exclamation on screen it was truly one
of the highlights of the ceremonies
opening monologue you know what I wasn't
talking so fast Sandra Oh like the joke
like went over my head and it wasn't
until I saw the clip on Twitter that
like I understood the whole thing it
wasn't until TV Guide explained it to me
yeah that was so funny like first of all
Emma Stone should be sorry for more than
one reason when it comes to a loja like
that movie never should have been made
just like as a film right I didn't even
I never saw it I never admitted to
seeing it I didn't realize that she
played a character of Hawaiian and
Chinese heritage I knew I didn't owe the
Chinese but I knew it was I gonna
Hawaiian movie and like homegirls not
Hawaiians right and she don't even look
a lion right and other does George
Clooney Brad Lee Cooper George Clooney
Bradley Cooper is the star of that movie
aloma yeah I'm pretty sure it's George
no no it's Bradley Cooper I sure stone
played Alison in the 2015 Cameron Crowe
film which also starred Bradley Cooper I
could like that's wrong it's you're
thinking of descendants what's like oh
when uh shailene woodley it's like
running in the neighborhood yeah that is
so different house it's also in Hawaii
okay
oh you're right yeah it is in Hawaii I
haven't seen either or it's in some
tropical [ __ ] no it's annoying
cool maybe sure yeah
anyways I mean go to go Don Imus Joan
for being self-aware
yeah and good on Sandra Oh for calling
out the injustice right of the whitewash
I mean
just as a sir because that movie was a
flop like and that's so embarrassing for
both of them like two people at the
Golden Globes going to the Oscars who
like have Aloha in their portfolio did
you think that Bradley Cooper got like a
little work done his face looked like
very smooth and puffy he looks great
yeah he looks great like he did Lee got
some work done for sure I bet it's
Hollywood
of course I mean everyone's doing
everything but then it's like when he
plays these movie somebody's like really
gritty characters with like fights yeah
wrinkly foreheads and like dirt caught
in their wrinkles right my Crowsnest
where does he get those and then he lays
up the Botox for a while like when he's
doing a Chris Kyle role because Chris
Kyle had wrinkles that could tell a
story
yes exactly wrinkles worth a thousand
words
the next story that's just saying the
world by storm is this Fiji water woman
who stole the spotlight at the Golden
Globes you know there's a lot of things
about our generation in our culture that
I despise but having to have like one
viral moment and make that person like
Instagram famous from every like live
television event is my least favorite
like the selfie kid didn't need to be
coming as the sunny kid is is the worst
of the kids um this girl is kind of
money and I'm just happy for her because
if you look at her Instagram which etags
like she really is like out here it's
11:11 Make A Wish I never show Network
show Network show a member jo-jo she's
really out here like trying to be an
Internet model I think she's signed with
Wilhelmina so life is good for this is
really good like sometimes you know Fame
happens to someone who's not prepared
for it and she's ready like she has all
of her CX and Ortiz and she's ready to
now become like look he's got the agent
already right she's got the DM for
inquiries already she has like the
mindset for it this isn't like Mason
Ramsey who's you know grandparents
needed to be like taught how to use
Instagram totally she's ready for this
viral moment so for that reason I'm
happy for her but then like you go look
at her Instagram and it's all like these
model Instagram shots you know like
Instagram model shot and like she really
doesn't look anything like she looked at
the Golden Globes last night and I do
have to give credit where credit is due
because the first place I saw this and
the first person to actually call it out
was shockingly they had a creative
thought of their own was II like they
tweeted it first they discovered her and
in the background like smiling um ya
know so good for her and she's gonna
like get some Fiji money now for sure
because she made Fiji like the star of
the show definitely and yeah now she's
like a good model
spokesperson and she's a model so now
she'll be famous like and she'll have
success in the career that she wanted
but that is like a [ __ ]
up on part of the Golden Globes like in
a prime spot where people are taking
pictures why do you have a waitress in
the background like that's not idea no
but it's like it seems as though people
took pictures all along the carpet and
she was stationed in one place and they
did want fiji water sponsorship so in
all the pictures that she happens to be
in she really melts the moment
understood so she wasn't in everyone's
pictures all the time but the ones that
she is in she's serving you know she she
opened rebus I came to serve she's
creepy like literally like with her
devil smile hmm hmm that's it's funny
stuff it is happy for her because I
shall have success now no one like this
like she could have been on The Bachelor
but this happened and this is faster and
easier
et not Oh The Bachelor is on tonight
you're not gonna watch I don't know like
I really struggle and it's like it's
just such a commitment timewise it's not
like and this is what I said tomorrow if
I'm home and it's on like I will watch
it in the background but I can't ever
catch up on an episode of The Bachelor
because it takes too much time
yeah but it's like tonight I have a
dinner like I just and then like I can't
I think tonight I'll definitely watch
tonight cuz it's the big episode and
we'll recap it cuz we'll get to know all
the girls I'm not gonna keep up every
week like I need to get to my life um
well just like we do with every other
show we'll talk about it when we have a
chance and when we're all caught up and
I'll watch tonight just to know all the
girls meet I don't know if Dana did
about your bracket I really I'm the
reigning champion and I really need to
make another one hundred twenty dollars
I just I wouldn't know like I would only
be watching it recapping it for the
toasters and the toasters seems like
hate The Bachelor franchise so why don't
you guys let me know like I'm only doing
it because I have a pit like I feel like
I'm letting you guys down like if you
don't even watch it like great let me
know let's hope for the best
let's hope for the best are you caught
up on Real Housewives of New Jersey yes
let's talk about at the a guy because
it's so funny it's so good
next story Melissa McCarthy secretly
he's handing out ham sandwiches at the
Golden Globes relatable to avoid the
sound of clinking cutlery on television
dinner at the Golden Globes dinners
largely served before the evenings
telecasted event leaving many actors
stranded on the red carpet but this year
Melissa McCarthy refused [ __ ] anyone
around her go hungry
her solution 30 hidden ham and cheese
sandwiches I've been handing them out to
everyone she told variety next year I'm
bringing hot dogs yeah it's gonna say
like a bring it in like reinforcements
like yes
bring pizza I mean nothing sounds worse
to me than a ham sandwich that should
like sitting in melissa mccarthy's SUV
for an hour what about some PB and J's
right those aged better than hot dogs
like you have to keep them warm they get
sweaty yeah I hate sweaty lunch meat me
too
oh so can we just talk for one second
that we didn't harp on was the flu shot
thing right it was very weird and like
Keith Urban literally like jumped back
and they tried to get him on they were
they were actual jealous weird until
they made a joke about anti Maxim that
was funny I put it on your head that was
really funny that was really funny dude
we're actually even actually get and I
saw I think it was Rachel Brosnahan who
got one that's so cuz her sleeve was out
like if you were honestly like Nicole
Kidman was safe she was wearing long
sleeves you know what's so weird I like
never gotten a flu shot do you ever get
them I got a flu shot what America's
like I'm an anti backs are like cuz it's
a pain in the ass yeah I guess you just
go to your local you can get a brain
read right but you have to like then you
have to go and get it like I remember
when I was working that you say like
have flu shots on site and so then like
you got a flu shot but people are so
like serious about them I got the flu
shot one year and it was also the year
that I got the flu and it introduces the
back right and they do you think that
that's a fluke like that's not supposed
to happen but I just feel like I'm very
unlucky when it comes to things like
that and I just I don't want to I don't
want to jinx myself like I'm probably
gonna get the flu anyway everyone gets
it like it's it's the winter like it's a
part of being alive and in New York
right or did I get the flu everyone yeah
yeah I think germs are more prevalent in
yeah because we're all touching this de
Blasio's world we're just living on it
right next story really shocking Kate
Beckinsale leaves Golden Globes party
with Pete Davidson love this because I
really need to talk about Pete Davidson
but read us the details Davidson Kate
Beckinsale were spotted leaving the
Netflix Golden Globes party together
they were flirting all night and sipping
my way champagne a spy told page six TV
who probably works for my way champagne
because this seems sponsored quote they
were outside on the patio and left
together SNL star Davidson fiance ariana
grande ended their engagement in October
after four months well good for them
Pete Davidson is looking so healthy like
he needed like he needed to get rid of
that hair and once he did I just thought
like his like his skins like got its
color back like he was looking a little
green yeah and I think the hair may
brought out the green yeah but what I
really wanted to talk about when it
comes to Pete Davidson I want to come
back to this is I just want
where the Machine Gun Kelly of it all
okay because Machine Gun Kelly flew to
New York when Pete's a button was in a
really bad like downward spiral they
went together last night to the the
InStyle party like they had that little
elevator thing of them smoking weed like
really cute and I just feel like Machine
Gun Kelly is really good friend I agree
and I think he really actually did help
bring Pete out of this like deep dark
place right and he was probably like bro
like let's go to the Globes like we'll
catch some tail yeah and I'm sure Pete
Davidson like never even expected in his
wildest dreams I would be like Kate
Beckinsale like they're the most
beautiful prominent like a
well-established like well-respected
actress in Hollywood right so I'm happy
for him because he deserves joy and love
and he needs it like I mean he's like
not in the realm of ariana grande no she
was too famous for him no not even like
on a Fame level like I don't think Kate
Beckinsale and ariana grande hang out so
like she doesn't have to worry about
like he can you know go into different
social circles right yeah so anyway they
just hooked up like and we never hear of
this again I'm just happy for him no but
it's just so funny cuz like when you
think of Machine Gun Kelly like he's all
tatted up like his starting fights
whatever and like you just don't think
of him as like a good friend that's
exactly what I mean you can't judge a
book by its cover
truly I look like Machine Gun Kelly
today with my shirt you're sure there's
nothing weird about your shirt bad way
are you serious I literally look like a
tatted up
Evanescence band what happened to lead
singer you got to mode in yet totally
okay so those are all the golden gold
stories where's there anything else that
you wanted to talk about when it came to
the Globes I don't look at the globe's
has no performances cuz they really want
to hear let it go right but then but
then you've got performances that you
don't want oh of course because for
example so at the Oscars you got each
song that's Naaman in the category he's
performed so that's show last night it
would have been all the stars from Black
Panther girl in the movie girl in the
movies from dumpling wreck reom for a
private war from private war revelation
from boy erased and shallow so like I
didn't have to sit through all four it's
not even like an accomplishment that
yellow one no no it was like not even
even a morsel of competition there right
because they refused to nominate great
showmen
so that's how you knock out the
competition truly you just are ignoring
talent that's bursting at the seams oh
my god are you okay you know I'm [ __ ]
pissed like that's the whole other thing
it's like how can you even have an award
show when in the greatest movie of the
year is completely and a brutally rebuff
can I tell you something so funny I was
in a cab and I got stopped like a light
and I was like next to
pay phone and the pay phone ad was from
one year ago it was agreed to show him
an ad it's so weird they took pay phones
aren't like a hot commodity anymore that
nobody wants to buy them so they
literally left the poster for greatness
showman in there it's like the greatest
advertisement ever it's not a quiet
street though I don't think it's very
popular and you know greatest showman is
just a timeless film so it can stay
there forever ribbon and literally says
like coming soon right it's like know
what Kayla no it's like says like
December 20th so you're like oh it just
came out right how exciting it was also
like the one-year anniversary on the day
that I saw and I'm like irony that's the
thing about irony it's ironic okay and
then we're doing one non globe story
because just something that happened
this weekend that must be discussed the
other night Kris Jenner tweeted out on a
video of kendall Jenner saying that she
can make a really big announcement was
very ambiguous it was very ambiguous on
Twitter
basically Kendall's saying like at 14
she started to you know realize that she
was going through something and that she
thinks they're talking about it will
help other people don't use her platform
to leverage so they took you know that
she's not the only one right and Kris
Jenner literally read this essay about
her Kendall is her hero like she is such
an inspiration she can't believe how
brave she's being so there was a lot of
speculation about what it was gonna be
it was really crazy that Kris Jenner was
able to like write such a long
captioning it was such a long video
without actually saying what it's about
like it was almost like a parody of just
talking about stuff right and a lot of
people were speculating like she was
gonna talk about living with anxiety
right like going through like because
she really out of all that like I said
worst social anxiety that's like
crippling so I thought was gonna be that
I'm like okay this is like a little like
weird make a video about it looking back
considering we all know that right and
she talks about it a lot right um but it
was not that she announced that she is
partnering with Proactiv was the big
announcement she is a new face of
Proactiv quote I feel great on the
inside and out kendall Jenner is keeping
up with Proactiv one year after
embracing her acne at the Golden Globes
the supermodel in reality stars the
latest spokesperson for a popular
dermatologist develop skincare line she
revealed during a commercial spot on
Sunday quote a lot of people have seen
me struggling with acne acne mostly
through paparazzi photos or the Golden
Globes she tells people exclusively I
had exhausted all other options and
decided to try Proactiv it really works
for me I feel great on the inside and
out it's just a very simple and easy
routine I love the cleanser and retinoid
acne treatment and everyone should use a
sunscreen jeah
it really helps having any vitamin so
every single day so here's the thing the
thing is the thing is is that I wasn't
really surprised that this was a huge
letdown because there everything that
Cardassians do is still manufacture like
if there's really something deep and
dark they don't want us to know and
we're never gonna find out so I didn't
think it was gonna be like what we
really thought it was gonna be but this
is just a whole other level of taking
advantage of like clickbait and people's
like vulnerability and go like
gullibility because they have made this
big announcement and had it having it be
like a literally a multi-million like
you're not brave for talking about your
acne if you're being paid millions of
dollars to do it sorry well so that's
the other thing how much you think she's
got I think that least 5 million oh
because it's commercials and it's
national commercials and she talks just
like embarrass herself and if you think
of the caliber of celebrities who've
done it before they only have top like
the Justin Bieber did it an oblivion did
it so they have Larry did it they have
top top talent doing it so they have
budget right and it's like she works
with the most high-end brands in the
world like Esther knows so for her to
like work with a brand like this I think
the pet the money had to be right yeah
and it was because Kris Jenner knows
that 10% is worth a lot I just like I'm
shook I really was so sure a lot of the
drugs called it but I wasn't shook
because I didn't expect much but I'm
just I'm I just couldn't believe I just
can't believe that they would take
advantage they would tee it up like that
like like making it a joke like you know
if she had just come out as the
spokesperson for practic we'd be like oh
my god this is great so in tune good for
her but when you make it seem like she's
about to change the world and like acne
medication and they're like like
monetizing off this moment last year
where she was on the red carpet and like
had some pimples which is like not a big
deal but they were actually gives us a
traumatic experience like so interrupt
her on her head and kidnapped her and
she was baby
and I did read a whole article um not an
article maybe like Facebook post from
someone who was an actual doctor talking
about how those pimples on her face from
last year were linear which is a very
odd pattern for adult acne it's like
pimples just come where they go they
don't go in a straight line and that it
either could have been like from fillers
or just for some sort of injection like
irritation like so couldn't even maybe
it wasn't even real acne this whole
thing is suffers from acne because she's
a because she's a woman who wears makeup
a lot and just came out of her teenage
years like right I get pimples all the
time right there's a difference between
pimples I want to say an acne and
Kendall
Jenner has pimples so do I I don't know
I don't know about that I think she's
like we definitely seen on the show that
she has like skincare issues so I'm not
gonna like say that she doesn't have
acne I just wasn't who does it know for
sure it's a it used to be like it's like
it's like this disease like everyone has
skin problems like some days are good
and some days are bad and sometimes
Kendall goes on my carbon she looks good
and somebody she has a breakout like
congrats right the Hawthorns been
talking about this for years acting like
it's a disease right Miley Cyrus's been
posting pimple cream selfies on her
Instagram for years no it's like they're
acting like how one kid like him like
it's Kim psoriasis it's not it's pimples
and it's very normal it's all and it's
so great that there's something out
there like proactive to help you to help
it's it's very interesting so anyways my
issue was with the lead up in the height
and congrats on the uncool new
partnership and the pay track like yeah
maybe she'll now upgrade her house or
something even though she just moved to
a house or a house in Calabasas and it
just got done like the membership in
this season her only storyline was like
the renovation right and like living
with Kim and then being like having
nowhere to live meanwhile your family
has like mansions all over the cosign
like so now she's finally in the house
like in real life like it just got
finished cool by the way is everyone
enjoying our new camera setup like I'm
enjoying it I'm enjoying it - I was also
noticing on the close-ups one I look
better on close-ups today but you never
have to thank God and - I was rewatching
last week's episode and like the
close-ups are also highlighting my
crooked teeth um you have crooked bottom
teeth - I could bottom - better than
cricket talk to you oh of course
and I've always been like kind of into
the crooked teeth could they like make
me feel like Miley even though she got
new teeth it makes me feel like Miley in
truth movie era um but now I think the
thing about crickety is like they just
continue to get worse would you ever do
like a like an invisible aligner yes so
I'm starting to work with candid Co oh
to reshape my crooked teeth like I don't
need them to be perfect teeth but
they're getting a little out it's really
better and it's like it's not good for
your sheets let them be so crooked right
so candid makes clear liners that are
sent directly to your home and are
customized specifically to straighten
your teeth the aligners fix crooked
teeth crowding protrusion and gaps the
first step is to purchase their modeling
kit which we send to your home so you
can take impressions of your teeth of
the modeling kit it's $95 so you are
just one step away from getting straight
whiter teeth take advantage of candids
risk-free modeling kit guarantee plus
when you use our dedicated link candid
co.com slash toast
you'll save 25% on your modeling kit
that's a lot that's candy coat calm
slash toast to get 25% off the price of
your modeling kit candid co.com slash
toes well I look forward to watching you
evolve a joey camasta who is gonna
co-host this week while I'm gone he does
invisible liners you should ask him
because I've seen him take them in and
out of his mouth I will ask you should
ask him like if he enjoys the process I
will I'm down for an invisible I can
also you know to wear them at the house
like we work from home most of the day
so just wear them inside know I sound
big deal I'm not ashamed of these teeth
well speaking of so here's housekeeping
amen then we have to rehab me Jersey
okay so I'm back I'm here today and I'm
here tomorrow yes I leave Wednesday to
which I'm actually leaving Theo in the
care of my Eva's aunt Jackie's gonna
take the Wednesday til Sunday because
Zac so amis bachelor party so you have
three or four days without him and then
like one or two days with him um how do
you feel like nervous excited I'm
feeling really excited obviously I'm a
little nervous um but I feel like this
is a necessary step in order for me to
figure out if I can handle a dog yeah I
think you can I think I can too but
it'll be a lesson for sure and I'll like
write out the whole schedule for you yes
and Theo is a precious angel of a man
until like even if I get a puppy it's
gonna be harder so working with like a
doctor and you know a political refugee
is gonna be easier than what it will
actually be like for me so if I can't
handle this I can't handle anything and
then so Wednesday Thursday Friday we're
gonna get co-host Thursday is joey
camasta Friday is Olivia yes and
Wednesday we're gonna see if any talent
comes into town that we want to scoop up
and with Olivia we're doing a whole
wedding recap we're having Josh from
virtue Ben design join us as a guest to
talk about like he designed her whole
wedding and he's doing mine and he's
just like creative guest card up on the
toast with questions which button so
feel free to just ask any questions
especially for Olivia cuz there was some
things that she revealed on the page on
but she did want to reveal before the
wedding right so now I want you to talk
about it right like you're open it'll be
a wedding extravaganza should we have
her wear her veil totally it would be so
funny okay let's talk about Jersey
Jersey cuz you're caught up and now the
worst thing I want to talk about because
it has nothing to do with the drama it's
Jennifer making fun of Jackie saying I
couldn't up winter with a more pompous
[ __ ] I don't think so
so I'm
struggling okay because with new girls
it's like hard to decide and for the
most part like I trust like when I'm on
Beverly Hills I'm like if Lisa Rinna and
Erika Jayne like someone I identify with
them well whoever they like I approve so
in in Jersey I really feel that way
about Melissa and Margaret like I know
them personally I love them I think
they're good people a creative good
values and they have a good judge of
character
so they decided to align themselves with
Jackie and who we met I mean that is
also really cool and I see them all
being friends which is in the context of
the show and it's hard to immediately
take yourself out of like having met
people person everyone tonight it's
Teddy Mellencamp syndrome right look we
better boot on the show we were like we
don't really get her then we met her she
was liber8 gorgeous sending her husband
came to support her she was so nice and
cool like I only have good thing and
anytime we've seen her since like just
the best the best sort of first oh yeah
we saw her at the weekly party and she
was like so with her friends like her
mom's friends it was so fun so that's
really where I struggle because love
Melissa and Margaret so much like I
think I consider Margaret like a close
personal friend and they decided to go
with Jackie and I'm just not there but
usually I trust the people that I trust
to like make good because they're there
I'm not there I'm just I don't like how
like strong she came in and she's like
coming for Teresa which is just like
don't and like I get her I get what
she's saying it's like you're like
you're like I'm not afraid of you I love
that like standing up whatever but like
I just don't like how strong she came in
and at first I wasn't really loving
Jennifer I loved her house and I loved
her basketball court I do think that the
article thing like that everyone's just
brushing off like brushing off like it's
not a big deal like yes okay you could
you could take it as complimentary but
it's incredibly [ __ ] up thing to have
someone invite you into their home like
with their kids in their family and for
you to like publicly write something
about it I ain't like that at all I
completely agree so on the Jacke at
first I liked Jackie
overall I liked her friendship with them
and I understood what she said - Teresa
it's like everyone was whoa whoa whoa
but like technically what she said was
true she made a point that completely
debunked Teresa's argument against
Melissa and no one likes that but I
really did like that she was because
everyone's afraid of Teresa like she's
the star of the show if Teresa doesn't
like you like you might not make it back
that's just that's how it is it's Teresa
show so her like standing showing like
I'm kind of here for it but when it came
to the article I
she was completely wrong it didn't even
matter what it said the fact that like
you said I didn't invite a reporter into
my home right
you're a friend and now I have to worry
that like everything that you do is
gonna be like written about like that's
a really weird thing to do and a huge
invasion of privacy and to not have
given even like a heads up the fact that
it was complimentary is completely like
it doesn't matter it could have been
mean or it could have been nice it does
it's irrelevant the fact that you have
someone coming to your home and they're
like judging just writing cookie morning
and and analyzing I really don't know
and I actually really do like Jennifer I
mean - and I like how she's like Jenny
so much about our culture she's like
Turkish Christian like I didn't know
anything about it and like they have all
these weird not we were sorry these
interesting traditions were like you buy
the dress and back to Giovanni and she
seems like a real Giovanni customer they
never like I need to go to Giovanni I
know I think they may be anyone for your
wedding we should make an appointment I
know I didn't I don't think you it's not
it's a showroom like so it's no size we
go there no I think it's like a showroom
like for a wholesale but the housewives
get to go and like try stuff on okay I
have like a lot of faith that someone
who's watching I've got to the point
show yeah please please like seriously I
need an after party so I'm just feeling
torn the wedding in Bimini was so funny
to galas out of control and the the
irony of this all is that in reality
they're now in real time they're
divorced ready so do you think that in
their interviews they would be speaking
like they are like when Joe is saying
this marriage isn't gonna last Margaret
say if they were still married right now
maybe they got divorced in a year from
now because they do those testimonials
every week right so it's nice to be
proven right right so and that's what
I'd love about Bravo is that someone Oh
Katie from anima Bruce told us that
she's like every week we have to go in
and recreate the same looks for
continuity and we talk about [ __ ] that
happened that week so it's not like
they're talking about it now like it's
all in real time even the side
commentary oh okay
did you do the same hair and makeup with
a bunch of times I feel like they only
do it once and then if they have to do
more like me it's ready to do it once
and then if they need more from that
look they'll do it again but like when
Joe Gorga is like I'm by the way Joe
Gorga is my favorite character did Joe's
the Joe do oh I love the job do they
love their friendship I love the four of
them as a squad the Joe duo taking on
Marty and then was so broke and it
wasn't a joke was so funny Marty is like
such a little [ __ ] starter like telling
Danielle Danielle
so crazy like that whole wedding was so
weird and then like it was like this
biggest traffic at wedding like I runs
in these big streets and then it's like
on the beach with plastic chairs and
there's like lounge chairs people at the
pool in the back there were so many
empty chairs like okay there were ten
people at the wedding but even if
there's ten people like like you know
already how many people are coming it
was very odd it was very odd and like
she had seven thousand bridesmaid it's
like she had more than me no it was so
odd it and I'm honestly really glad that
Danielle and Margaret are done being
friends because Margaret deserves better
and she really treats Margaret so
differently like the treat
Teresa could slapped me on the face I'm
acting out wouldn't book didn't Teresa
is Danielle's meal ticket like right but
like Margaret like the bar not only is
Margaret an incredible friend but like
the bar is even higher than that and
like she's always like yelling at her
it's so rich she really treats her
different kind of girls but one thing I
didn't agree with Margaret on is like
she was totally justified in her
feelings but like don't don't start it
and I don't have the fight on the day of
the wedding like even though like she
was being a crazy bridezilla it is still
her wedding she didn't talk about it
tomorrow no she was like I'm going home
I'm getting on the plane right but that
was after like hours of like badgering
and making her feel bad no good I know
but like do it tomorrow and it's like
she showed up no makeup no hair that was
our crazy and you're gonna start like
being mean and having fights like when
I'm literally sitting here like I've
bared it all for you that was so crazy
how like they all she wrote an email she
said come fresh-faced they all literally
they all do the same they all came with
wet hair and no makeup which was very
brave I would never do that on TV and
they it's her fault she only had one
glam person for makeup and one Glenn
burgers in her face and the way she like
yells at each of them like first Melissa
shoes means her Teresa like just was
like sit down and then Margaret she like
went off and it's like and Margaret did
around her all did the same thing wrong
so it's like that's how she treated in
do it wrong they said she wrote us an
email with an itinerary technically but
like she was they equally we're in the
wrong according to her and she treated
them all so differently so I'm really
glad that Margaret is sticking up for
herself she doesn't need to hang out she
doesn't like I'm here for the friendship
of Margaret and Dolores and here me too
here's the crux of be like Dolores I
like to Loris to mark she's mad at
Margaret for being friendly with Dolores
like going to things filming with her
blah blah blah Teresa and Dolores are
best best best best friends and she
never said a word to Teresa
such a great analogy I like to Loras I
think she's like I feel like she might
not have that much of like a long-term
stint on the show because she's really
not
like in it with the girls like she's
close with Teresa she's like individual
friendships but she's not like a part of
the group so much do you mean yeah but I
think I think people I think the fans
really like her I love her and I think
she's a really good friend to Teresa
yeah which I like yeah and and she she
needs to just have her own like she
before she was only getting in fights on
behalf of city now she's only in fights
on behalf of Teresa like she needs her
own stand her ground but when it was
actually her fight with Danielle is
keeping the show moving so her and her
Frank were in the kitchen and they found
the article like that was such that was
real like Bravo didn't know she wrote
the article like if they had to read it
like no one else would have really cared
it's like a local newspaper it's not
even it's up in your time Bergen Record
yeah right
the shoujo of the newspaper and Jennifer
was like what you wanna check the Bergen
Record Jennifer was like know who [ __ ]
it's the Bergen Record no that was that
was not cool
no not cool at all I'm gonna an
agreement and the one thing that we
didn't talk about the Golden Globe said
I just like can't believe and we need to
reevaluate our lives is ill-equipped oh
my god oh my god oh my god I'm annoyed
because like I have to be at EP G's in
25 minutes oh [ __ ] you didn't tell me
that sorry it's okay um we need to talk
about
I broke the story I just want to say
because I'd heard some rumors there was
a media alert sent out because she was
wearing Lorraine Schwartz earrings and
like that's a part of just like the hot
like they say who you running so they
got a media learnt that she was there
obviously the close personal friend of
the Kardashians right which is right and
it also made sense because Joe was in
the favorite he was there they walked
completely separately on on the carpet
for the after-party
he walked alone at the Golden Globes she
like snuck in with aegis Alba she
perform she presented the most
prestigious award she was amazing I had
thought like a while ago that she had
her boobs done and this was like she's
not really she doesn't bear her chest
because she's a nice girl but this was
the first time I really notice like she
doesn't got her boobs done a good first
she looked amazing I loved her dress I
loved just like the pictures of her and
etirsa elbows daughter who was mrs.
Golden Globe that they usually make that
a bigger deal like I agree for little
Elsie Grammer there's our second
announcement where was the justice for
mrs. Elba I don't know I agree um the
cella tripped up at all like and like
I'm sure she got to choose which award
she presented like where she wanted to
kiss Lady Gaga on the cheek so she went
in for two kisses and Lady Gaga only
went in for one that was a very small
detail that everyone missed don't worry
about it
and then when they were walking off they
were like hugging each other like their
two true icons who respect one another
and then someone pulled up a tweet it
was so cute like an exchange from 2013
and it was like Taylor stuff like is
anyone else like just seeing like Lady
Gaga like living her fullest life right
now and Lady Gaga respond was like I'm
gonna think
so much like one day your prince
charming look common like now she's
heard to go the globe with her prince
charming and she they're about to get
engaged and it's like Lady Gaga called
it cuz she's a witch but like in a good
way and Lady Gaga was sitting next to
her fiance Christian with her back to
him yes I see a love with Brad he had
his hand on her back the whole time like
he was keeping an eye on his fiancee I
mean he should she's a she's a hot hot
piece of meat okay so we're back
tomorrow regular fast v bachelor me
kappa light will say that's all we got
make sure if all the morning just on
Facebook Instagram YouTube with Monday
morning show we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube and we're also available as a
podcast where podcasts can be listened
to stitch or Spotify Apple cashbox
public radio all the places and that's
what we got for you it's been an
absolute pleasure hanging out with you
have a wonderful day millenials bye
you